[Musique]
êtes vous sûr que vous même vous
considérez un noir du même oeil qu'un
blanc ce couple que nous avons filmé
dans les rues de paris à l'insu des
passants comment leur garderiez-vous
vous avec surprise avec mépris avec
dégoût vous pensez peut-être que nous
avons simplifié le problème que la
situation est trop particulière nous
n'avons pas choisi au hasard cette
situation elle est l'une des plus
révélatrices qui soit
c'est un test si vous voulez on se
trahit souvent par la réaction tout
instinctif que l'on laisse échapper
devant un tel couple vous le voyez en ce
moment vous allez l'entendre dans
quelques instants
il est difficile de le nier le préjugé
racial existe en france en général il
n'est pas agressif il s'agit seulement
d'un certain regard d'une certaine façon
de s'exprimer
monsieur je vais vous poser quelques
questions je vais vous demander de me
répondre
vraiment spontanément cherchant quelle
est la réponse que vous donneriez si les
choses vous arrivent et si un étudiant
chinois revenez vous demander une
chambre à luis à supposer que vous en
ayez une
est ce que ça vous gênerait de la lui
louer pas du tout au contraire est-ce
que si votre fille venez vous voir en
vous disant qu'elle veut d'épouser un
noir ça vous paraît très gênant c'est
déjà beaucoup plus délicat c'est parce
que plus délicate la chambre ce site
c'est une chose et sa fille c'était
justement si j'ai une fille qui a 18 ans
qui passe son baccalauréat maintenant ça
demande réflexion je ne sais pas comme
ça en deux secondes que je poserai comme
ça que ça arriverait elle viendrait elle
vous dirai non parce que je connaissais
fréquentation alors sa demande tout de
même peut-être quand je dis oui non
peut-être cette petite fille quand elle
sera grande elle venait vous voir en me
disant papa je voudrait épouser un noir
comment est-ce que vous réagiriez mais
je crois que la direction ne serait plus
tôt enfin un peu amer parce que c'est
pas que on va pas les noirs mais enfin
malgré tout se passe comme ça fait
quelque chose auprès des amis auprès des
parents les y retient il a une fille qui
se mariait cannois mais il me semble que
après tout après les avoir connus ces
gens là peut-être mon fils sont des gens
très bien quoi ce serait dur mais si
vraiment liquides
on peut pas les contrats vous êtes pour
la liberté oui madame si votre fille
vous annonçait qu'elle veut épouser un
noir est ce que ça vous gêne drake un
petit peu monsieur parce que je suis
blonde et elle aussi alors vraiment il
ya une différence de choses mais enfin
peut pas dire que ça me fait très
plaisir quand même vous essayer de la
faire revenir sur sa décision
oui je crois qu'est ce que vous lui
diriez pas je lui dirai que il ya des
blancs quand même sur la terre
il ya des choses qu'il ne faut pas
confondre oui faut pas confondre mais
enfin je les méprise pas du tout juste
estime que nous sommes des frères les
noirs et prix les blancs quel âge avez
vous mademoiselle 15 me vous comptez
vous marier un jour oui est-ce que vous
envisageriez d'épouser un noir nous non
vous n'avez jamais pensé non jamais est
ce que si par hasard un camarade que
vous auriez noir vous demander en
mariage
comment est-ce que vous réagiriez je te
montre d'abord la ville mes parents et
en dehors de ça vous êtes plutôt content
oui pourquoi
pour les enfants ce qu'est ce que vous
pensez qu'ils pourraient arriver aux
enfants à l'école ne serait pas pareil
que les autres c'est pas le même mieux
ses propos sans gravité ces regards
révélateur imaginez-vous leurs
conséquences avez vous essayé de vous
mettre dans la peau d'un noir d'un jaune
d'un arabe d'un juif vivant en france en
1961 dans l'atelier où nous nous
trouvons il est évident que le problème
des races ne se pose pas puisque sont
réunis là un algérien un africain un
asiatique
ils sont là tous les trois au milieu de
camarades qui eux aussi sont de races
diverses
ça n'est donc pas sur leur vie
professionnelle actuelle que je vais les
interroger mais sur leur vie
professionnelle et sociale avant qu'ils
arrivent ici il ya longtemps monsieur
vous êtes en france
oui 1950 est ce que dans votre vie en
dehors de votre métier ou dans votre
métier vous avez eu des difficultés
parce que vous étiez alger ayari y en
avait eu des difficultés au moment de
chercher de travail ou
cherchez logement chercher que quelque
chose comme ça on trouve toujours
machin mais pas difficile mentalement on
vit et on vous fait sentir que c'est
parce que vous êtes à jouer
il y en a qui m'ont dit pas tout le
monde bien à comme on dit oui vous leur
dites quelque chose à sera bien sûr je
joue encore toujours l'occasion de leur
répondre
on retrouve toujours l'occasion de lui
répondre qu'est ce que je vous dis à
vous j'ai dit je suis algérien mais je
suis via des maras issue alger juste pas
été le vôtre moi je veux pas être
français ou ya chez nous aux biens
américains ont bien autrement je suis
algérien juriste algérien puis site où
vous êtes arrivé que les gens vous
disent retourné de gouverner oui ça
arrive
qu'est ce que vous faites dans ces
cas-là strict et je marque c'est marrant
parce que le général ils se rendent pas
compte de ce qu'ils disent vous essayer
de leur expliquer ou pas dit des fois
j'essaye a fait comprendre à ceux qui
veulent vraiment comprendre et ceux qui
sont vraiment débordé alors mais si je
n'y peux rien il y en a qui comprennent
y en a qui comprennent qu est ce que ça
a était grave pour vous dans votre vie
est ce que ça vous a vraiment fait des
complications est ce que ça vous a
empêché de prendre un métier est-ce que
ça va empêcher de trouver un logement
point de vue logement oui évidemment
c'est ce qui se posent dans toute la
ville de paris il ya des moments quand
je suis arrivé pour avoir une chambre
c'était vraiment difficile parce que ma
peau était noir est sûre ça je dirait
vraiment que s'il n'y avait que m'a posé
ne donne rien
je n'y peux rien non plus pour pouvoir
avoir une chambre je peux faire garder
bafoue et coucher dehors et vous
monsieur depuis combien de temps
êtes-vous en france 809 ça fait plus de
vingt ans revit tanguy est ce que vous
avez eu l'occasion de souffrir du fait
que vous étiez jo n'est pas blanc non
pour moi c'est naturel
est ce qu'il ya des gens qui vous ont
quelquefois fait des réflexions
sauvegarde parce ça vous fait rien si on
fait rien ça va mais on prépare la
sortie par la suite vous n'essayez même
pas de discuter mais non c'est pas au fn
c'est pas la peine vous croyez que non
c'est pas vrai discuter avec si j'avais
quitté afin que c est comme eux c'est
pareil c'est comme si vous étiez comme
il vous est déjà arrivé d'avoir
quelqu'un dans votre accident vous
saviez que ça le gêne et c'est à dire
une fois il y avait une femme alors qu
il y avait un confort alors qu'ils
étaient en tête alors la reconnais que
c'est un algérien elle revient vers moi
et la patrie se vider la tête en me
disant j'ai pas voulu prendre celui de
tête parce que c'est un algérien n avait
pas reconnue vous l'étiez nino ils ont
peur les jambes voulaient gêné vous
plutôt rare les jeunes vous qu'on
parlait on est plutôt contents ou ici en
france dans le métro il arrive souvent
que l'africain lorsqu'il monte dans le
métro brusquement toutes les têtes se
tournent vers lui sur certains visages
remarque soit
et puis
chez d'autres marques eu juste le regard
observateur en quelque sorte vous qu'est
ce que ça vous fait intérieur au début
ça m'a choqué parce que je me demandais
si je n'étais pas une bêtise oh et puis
petit à petit j'ai trouvé ça normal ou
presque
évidemment peut-être maintenant les
conditions actuelles politiques
ils sont pour quelque chose c'est même
probable
vous les sentez aussi avoir une action
sur les rapports que vous avez avec les
gens les conditions actuelles des
conditions politiques
oui oui mais ça s'explique qu'est ce
qu'on voulait il faut bien tant que
remplaçante de en guerre et je sais pas
je crois qu'il est normal que certains
français qu'ils sont pas complètement
informés ou pas très bien informé prouve
une certaine d'adversaires adversaires
mais ça c'est une vraie information mais
cela suppose j'ai eu l'occasion de
développer installe dans une entreprise
et après avoir discuté avec les
directeurs sur les modalités du plan de
price et terra ou marché très bien et
finalement il m'a fait savoir qu'il
n'était pas question que je sorte avec
une fille de la maison se retrouver à
ben sûr par la question elle-même
d'autant plus que c'est la première fois
que j'avais un contact personnel avec ce
monsieur
alors je trouve que cette attitude
provient uniquement du racisme et vous
pensez que dans ce cas là il n'y a rien
à faire il n'y a rien à faire vu qu'on a
affaire à un directeur d'entreprise qui
contrôlent si vous voulez 100 ou 200
personnes qui économiquement socialement
et très bien assis non il n'est pas trop
s'y dispute avec ce genre de personne si
votre fille rend pas chez vous et vous
disait papa je voudrais poser un noir
est ce que ça vous j'aimerais vraiment
ça ne plairait pas du tout maintenant si
c'était son désert on se laisserait
faire vous discuté un peu avec
certainement qu'est ce que vous lui
diriez jeunes restent pas sa place
premièrement ce n'est ce que je n'aime
pas ça pour moi personnellement et je
pense que pour elle ça n'irait pas
s'appeler la chair et dans son âme lions
oui est-ce que 6 1
chaude venait se présenter chez vous
louer une chambre il se présente chez
vous est ce que ça vous gênerait de lui
louer une chambre elle sera grande je
répondrais non ça ne me gênerait pas
jaloux je vous dirais sur le lourd et
cendrier non des moindres est non plus à
la bonne raison je suis allé dans ses
plis lâché j'ai pu le juger
vous n'aimez pas ces gens est ce que
vous considérez vous que vous faites du
racisme êtes raciste moi je crois en
vous n'êtes pas raciste connu toi est ce
que vous êtes anti raciste parce que
c'est quelqu'un vous est raciste
je n'aime pas que j'aie jamais même pas
quelqu'un qui combat une race souge
aucun sou je dirais par exemple quand
l'atavisme ou cas où pareille par
exemple que quelqu'un n'aime pas les
bras c'est d'accord c'est permis à tout
le monde
madame je vois vous avez une nombreuse
famille oui vous avez des filles n'ont
que des garçons et des gardons c'est un
nouveau garçon revenir un jour en vous
disant qu'il veut épouser une jeune
noire ça vous gênerait non je m'y
opposerai parce que j'ai un frère que
dans l'aviation belge qui a été tué par
les noirs au congo au mois de juillet
alors le fait place me laisse toujours
un souvenir je vous dirais désagréable
largement une chose comme ça est ce que
vous l'auriez envisagée non je n'aurais
pas envisager parce que je crois qu'il
ne faut pas mêler les races pourquoi
parce que je crois que deux se sont
formés aux montres des individus qui
sont qui sont détestés des noirs est
détesté des blancs je crois que le métis
n'est pas une chose à souhaiter voilée
que ce serait pour leur malheur je le
crois est ce que vous considérez qu'il
ya un problème juif en france
bon je crois que le problème juif est un
problème mondial actuellement
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
écoutez moi personnellement je ne suis
pas suffisamment peut-être à la hauteur
pour le juger mais je ne les apprécie
pas bon je ne leur fera aucun mal si
vous
mais enfin autant j'aimerais pas comment
office épouse un noir je ne verrai pas
d'un très bon gré s'il épousait une
juive avec les catégories doivent rester
entre elles je crois on ne croit qu'aux
temps possible c'est qu'il faut baisser
les niveaux entre eux parce que sans ça
on fait des déclassés je crois est ce
que vous estimez que vous êtes raciste
non je ne suis pas raciste et je trouve
que tout ce qui se passe maintenant je
suis d'avis de messer les blancs avec
noir dans les écoles je trouve pas qu'il
faut les traiter comme des bêtes et les
tortures et parce qu'ils sont noirs
parce que malgré tout ils n'y peuvent
rien
madame vous avez des filles 3 3 oui
quels agents tels 26 en dressant et ça
compte
si celle qui a très envie de vous voir
dans cinq ans peu près vous disait maman
je voudrais bouger un noir est ce que ça
vous gêne révélerait beaucoup et celle
me plairait pas pourquoi parce que
j'estime que chaque race doit rester
entre elles est ce que si vous aviez une
chambre à louer et qu'un chinois avait
proposé pour l'occuper ça vous gêne
oui beaucoup pour les mêmes raisons pour
les mêmes raisons rentrée meuriot la
cohabiter non est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que vous êtes ce qu'on
appelle raciste
pas tout à fait non mais j'estime que
chacun doit rester à sa place
est ce que vous estimez qu'il ya un
problème juif ça il a toujours existé
sous quelle forme
il ya eu des divergences d'idées en a
qui sont pour d'autres ils sont contre
moi même je vous dis j'estime que chacun
doit rester à sa place
on pensait tous avec les juifs ne sont
pas comme les autres en plus les juifs
les noirs chacun doit rester chez lui
on a peut-être un peu plus de place en
france pour élever nos enfants
c'est au nom de ces principes que se
font les croisades les guerres de
religion les massacres de populations ne
pas croire à l'égalité des races s'est
justifié par avance la persécution et le
génocide
est ce que vous croyez monsieur à
l'égalité des races non absolument pas
je suis persuadé qu'il ya des races qui
sont supérieures à d'autres races mais
je crois aussi que chaque race est
persuadé de la supériorité de sa race et
du groupe ethnique auquel il appartient
sur les autres vous vous croyez donc à
la supériorité de la race blanche ne
disons pas de la race blanche
disons d'une manière encore plus
dubitative aux blancs de culture
occidentale
vous croyez à la supériorité de ce
groupe ethnique sur les autres oui c'est
je crois une chose tout à fait normale
c'est une chose tout à fait normal parce
que quand on a été élevé selon certains
principes et qu'on a adopté ces
principes
on veut forcément qu'ils soient les
meilleurs du monde
quand on a été élevé pendant depuis tout
enfant jusqu'à l'âge à peu près d'hommes
on entend dire que la joconde était le
plus beau tableau du monde
on ne peut pas ne pas penser que la
joconde n'est pas le plus beau tableau
du monde on en est persuadé et on est
persuadé qu'à côté de cela
l'art khmer par exemple où les statues
venant d'indonésie sont moins belle
est ce que vous vous souvenez d'une
circonstance vous absenter plus disons
raciste que les gens qui vous entourent
eh oui nous plusieurs n'ont fait son
étude très précise qui me revient à
l'esprit je vais et ses invités à la
naissance d'un bébé non pas la naissance
que si vous voulez obas iam ou cérémonie
de baptême alors il y avait un repas etc
d'abord la cuisine
nous paraissait moins bonne que la
cuisine française est passée de dix ans
dans un pays encore français avec à
l'extérieur de france et donc j'avais
été invité à cette année à ce baptême et
on m'a montré le bébé et tout le monde
le trouvait beau vraiment il était beau
d'après tous les gens et bien vraiment
même en me forçant je n'ai pas pu le
prouver beau parce que nous risquons
n'est absolument pas à ce que
j'attendais au point de beauté d'un bébé
il rassemblait pas la joconde
il est difficile à n'importe quel bureau
de la joconde à quel moment notre vie
mettons-nous le doigt dans l'engrenage
diabolique
la réaction la plus naturelle la plus
innocente celle du jeune enfant qui
s'accrochent solidement à la catégorie à
laquelle il appartient
qui ne veut pas se distinguer des autres
n'est-elle pas déjà un réflexe raciste
est ce que tu es des couleurs est ce que
tu aimes le blanc pourquoi tu aimes le
blanc qu'est-ce que physique
est ce que tu es donc ça fait propre
leblanc oui est ce que tu aimes le noir
pourquoi parce que c'est trop sale
est ce que tu aimes les histoires
d'indiens wii qui tu préfères dans les
histoires de d'indiens les blancs ou les
indiens les blancs pourquoi
quand on peut faire quelque chose on a
des raisons pourquoi tu préfères les
blancs je me sais qu'ils sont pareils
crimes dans l'école ici il ya des petits
enfants qui n'ont pas la même couleur de
peau que toi tu les aimes bien c'est des
camarades
est ce que tu aimerais être comme toi de
mieux et si tu te trouvais en afrique
dans une école tous les petits enfants
seraient noirs et toi tu serais blanc tu
aimerais bien non pourquoi est ce que
quand je suis dans une école etc les
autres sauts noir de miettes noir si
c'était blog jean de laur et si tu te
trouvais en afrique
tu serais dans une école où tous les
enfants seraient les petits noirs et
puis toi tu serais blanc ah non pourquoi
parce que hier avec un ciel bien ça
serait moi ça donnerait oui est-ce que
si un matin tu te réveilles es et tu
étais comme jeter un petit noir tu
aimerais vous n'aimerez pas et si tu te
trouvais en afrique dans une école où
tous les petits enfants seraient noirs
et toi tu serais blanc c'est ce que tu
aimerais pourquoi
est ce que tu aimerais être à l'école en
afrique
comme eux ils sont ici en france c'est à
dire que tu serais dans une école où
tous les petits entrant renoir et il n'y
a que toi qui serait blanc comme les
autres dans ton école ici il y a des
petits garçons de couleurs y en a qui
sont noirs y en a qui sont jaunes tu les
aimes bien oui il y en a qui sont des
amis si tu te réveiller un matin et que
tu étais devenu comme commun de tu seras
un petit noir tu aimerais non pourquoi
et si c'était le contraire tu serais en
afrique dans une école tous les petits
enfants seraient noirs et toi tu serais
le seul petit en tremblant tu aimerais
pourquoi parce que je sens maintenant
route
[Musique]